Fox News contributor Ari fler and former
senior advisor to president Trump Steven
Miller and Congressman Byron Donalds is
right here on set with us in New
Hampshire how are you good to see you
I'm doing good how are you I'm good okay
analyze tonight what do you see big
night for president Trump uh look this
thing is over we know this this was
going to be Nikki Haley's biggest
opportunity she's 10 points down with
50% of the vote in this is like when you
start off on those roller coasters Shan
and you start really low that's where
she started 1 2% you crush all the way
up you think things are going well and
then you go over the edge and it's
downhill from there South Carolina is
not going to go well for her Nevada is
not going to go well for her Florida is
not going to go well for her it's time
for the party to unite this primary is
over but she wants to hang around so
we're going to have to beat her in a
couple more States Alli fler your take
sir yeah unless Nikki Haley is able to
make deeper in routs with the group that
represents most Republicans which is
conservative Republicans I think she's
going to hit a plateau and she might be
there right now with about 45% in a
State that's quite friendly toward a
Nikki Haley candidacy so when she says
she started at 2% and has moved up she's
right and she should get credit for
being the last woman standing but in
politics that's not good enough and the
the fundamental things she hasn't come
to terms with yet is conservatives love
Donald Trump and she hasn't been able to
crack that that'll be a problem in South
Carolina as well I suspect all right uh
we can see that that Trump is up a full
10 uh percentage points right now step
Miller um people that I know crunching
numbers texting me you know they think
the number is going to be closer to 13
14 maybe even 15% uh regardless uh I I
agree with Ari if if there was a state
that was suited for a more independent
more moderate Republican it would be the
the state of New Hampshire um and then
heading into your own home state four
years from now there's going to be an
Open Primary does Nikki Haley if you're
a campaign manager and you want her to
be president one day does she look at
the idea of maybe losing her home state
right now down 30.2% real clear politics
average does she take that risk and
continue or is it better to say I'll
come back in four years and I think I'll
have a better
opportunity well you would think that
she would try to avoid the Staggering
humiliation of what is setting up to be
a historic defeat in her home state and
as your other guests have mentioned New
Hampshire was where she bet everything
it would have been the perfect state for
her and not only is she going to lose by
significant double digigit margin but
she's going to lose despite the fact
that a record number of unaffiliated and
Democrat voters participated in the
primary a record low according to EXO's
47% of New Hampshire Republican primary
voters were actually Republican and yet
Donald Trump still Notch this massive
Victory so it's an even more significant
Victory than it appears on paper for
Donald Trump tonight yeah I agree uh I
got to tell you so as you go from here
if you're Donald Trump do you start
beginning the transition to a a general
campaign against Joe Biden I would like
to see more focus on Biden than maybe
Nikki Haley I don't think it's going to
be necessary in the next two states well
I totally believe that's what needs to
happen over at the at Joe Biden's
campaign they're already starting to
gear up in their mind they think it's
about about Donald Trump and that's
going to be their focus that needs to be
the focus of the Republican Party in the
Trump campaign it's about November Shan
the primary contest is over do you think
it's over Ari fler 10 seconds I don't
think it's over but I think Donald Trump
missed an opportunity tonight in that
speech he should have gone after Joe
Biden and ignored Nikki Haley and those
are opportunities you don't get too
often set a sights on Biden that's a
smart thing for Donald Trump I would
have preferred to hear more about Biden
uh all right thank you all three Stephen
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page Ag and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else